[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique sur lcp et public
sénat très heureuse de vous retrouver
nous sommes ensemble pour une heure
d'émission l'actualité est chargée
puisque nous sommes à moins de 15 jours
du premier tour des élections
législatives la campagne officielle
s'ouvre ce lundi pour le premier tour
qui se tiendra le 12 juin prochain mais
l'actualité ce sont aussi ces scènes de
chaos au stade de france samedi soir qui
font réagir les oppositions va essayer
d'y voir plus clair sur les
dysfonctionnements sur les
responsabilités aussi on va parler de
l'ukraine alors qu'un journaliste a été
tué aujourd'hui on l'a appris tout à
l'heure alors qu également catherine
colonna effectué sa première visite en
tant que ministre des affaires
étrangères à kiel première visite aussi
d'un représentant français sur place
dans un car dehors kamprad lui et
clément méric nous rejoindront pour
interroger notre invité sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur les retraites le gel des
loyers ou encore la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et puis enfin notre
partenaire le figaro sera bien
représentée avec vincent roux qui sera
en duplex dans quelques instants et bien
sûr ils thréard à la fin de cette
émission pour parler de tous ces thèmes
nous recevons patrick mignola bonsoir
bonsoir
vous êtes président du groupe modem ici
à l'assemblée nationale merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je le disais en
titre le journaliste français frédéric
leclerc imhoff a été tué aujourd'hui en
ukraine par un éclat d'obus alors qu'il
accompagnait des civils à bord d'un bus
humanitaire emmanuel macron a redit le
soutien inconditionnel de la france aux
journalistes qui font le difficile
métier d'informer sur des théâtres de
guerre catherine colonna la ministre des
affaires étrangères a condamné un double
crime qui vise un convoi humanitaire et
un journaliste c'est un crime de guerre
patrick mignola sans aucun doute et moi
je pense d'abord à sa famille ses
proches
je pense à sa rédaction bfm et puis à
tous les journalistes parce qu'on dit
jamais assez que pour nous informer
parce que nous ne connaîtrions pas les
crimes de guerre
connaîtrions pas ce qu'est la situation
sur le terrain on pourrait pas se faire
notre propre opinion cerci avait pas des
journalistes comme lui comme tous les
autres aujourd'hui qui symbolise on
serait dans la situation du peuple russe
qui ne sait pas ce qui se passe sur son
dans son propre pays est-ce qu'on peut
encore envoyer des journalistes dans
lequel
je crois qu'on doit
je crois qu'on doit c'est très difficile
c'est leur choix personnel
mais il est impératif que on ne puisse
pas mentir aux populations et les seuls
qui nous préserve du mensonge ce sont
les journalistes donc faut simplement
lui rendre hommage aujourd'hui il faut
une enquête il faut évidemment une
enquête internationale il faut savoir
pourquoi alors qu'ils étaient dans un
bus de civils il faut rappeler ça
il a pris un éclat d'obus ça veut dire
que ce but ce
qu'avait dit civil qui fuyait pour des
raisons humanitaires un endroit où il
pouvait plus rester sur le territoire
ukrainien ça veut dire que ce bus a été
bombardé et donc c'est un élément de
plus deux des horreurs qui sont commises
par l'armée russe en ukraine
catherine colonna la nouvelle mine était
affaires étrangères était actif
aujourd'hui où elle a rencontré vladimir
celle un ski il y va pour apporter le
soutien évidemment du peuple français au
peuple ukrainien pourquoi le président
français emmanuel macron ne se rend pas
à kiev il a été invité plusieurs fois
déjà
alors je vais vous dire ce que j'en
pense personnellement parce que
évidemment ça fait pas partie de mes
prérogatives ni de mes compétences comme
simplement parlementaire moi je crois
que le président de la république devra
un jour aller à kiev pour finaliser une
négociation et je comprends bien qu'il
ait une sorte de frustration des
populations occidentales et des médias
quand du mal à imaginer qu'on est sans
doute face à une guerre longue or c'est
ce qui va se passer et donc il faut
qu'on poursuive la ligne qui a été fixé
par le président de la république qui à
la fois une ligne de dialogue et de
sanctions avec la russie faut pas dire
qu'on continue à rechercher dans les
jours qui viennent une solution à
l'échelle européenne pour qu'on continue
pas à acheter du pétrole russe et donc
indirectement à financer la guerre parce
que là andré a bloqué aujourd'hui - et
donc l'embargo sur le pétrole russe et
donc avec la hongrie
comment on peut trouver néanmoins une
position européenne
de l'action européenne en tout cas tout
ça posera des questions
institutionnelles dans les années qui
viennent notamment sur la règle de
majorité la règle d'unanimité à
l'échelle de l'union européenne sa
menace la cohésion finalement l'union
européenne
le la règle de l'unanimité
menace la capacité d'action politique de
l'union et si comme je le pense nous
vivons dans un monde de plus en plus
incertain est de plus en plus dangereux
nous avons besoin demain d'avoir une
souveraineté stratégique militaire
économique à l'échelle de l'union
européenne la règle d'une ligne de
l'unanimité ne pourra pas s'appliquer
attention quand on remet en cause la
règle de l'unanimité ça signifie que ces
y compris la parole de la france qui
parfois pour être contredite par une
règle majoritaire mais je crois qu'il
faut accepter ça parce que désormais on
a besoin de protéger à nouveau le
territoire européen et pour terminer ce
que ce que nous visions sur l'ukraine je
crois qu'il faut qu'on continue et c'est
tout le sens de la présence de catherine
colonna sur le terrain faut qu'on
continue aussi une ligne de soutien et
de financement à l'ukraine parce que
nous serons dans une guerre longue et
qu'il faut que l'ukraine puisse
continuer de se défendre alors la
diplomatie continue en attendant
emmanuel macron et et olaf scholz ont
demandé ce week end à à vladimir poutine
d'entamer des négociations
rect et sérieuse avec volodymyr zèle
inscrit est-ce que vous pensez que la
dîmière poutine va s'arrêter s'il n'a
pas remporté au moins une victoire et
peut-être dans le donbass ce que je
pense ne compte pas
ce que je crois ce que j'espère c'est
que
emmanuel macron qui je crois a été un
très bon représentant de l'union
européenne depuis le début de cette
guerre va poursuivre et amplifier les
efforts il ya
probablement un argument que pour
entendre la dîmière poutine c'est si
l'europe est capable de se mettre
d'accord pour arrêter d'acheter du
pétrole russe je sais que c'est un
effort qui est plus important dans
d'autres pays qu'en france puisque nous
sommes beaucoup moins dépendants du
pétrole parce que nous avons du
nucléaire et que nous avons beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité c'est un effort très
important que nous demandons à nos
partenaires allemands qui ont renoncé au
nucléaire et donc sont très dépendants
du pétrole russe c'est un effort très
important qu'on demande aux italiens
quand une augmentation de 70 % de leur
prix d'énergie 70% du prix de l'énergie
c'est la seule manière de faire c'est la
seule sanction
je crois pour que les armes cessent
il faut que les portefeuilles s'assèche
on passe à une autre actualité avec
cette réunion ministérielle qui s'est
tenue en urgence ce matin pour cerner
les dysfonctionnements au stade de
france je vous rappelle la finale de la
ligue des champions a été perturbé
samedi soit de nombreux supporters n'ont
pu accéder au stade en raison d'un
trafic de 30 à 40 mille faux billets qui
a bloqué temporairement l'entrée du
stade de france à saint-denis par la
ministre des sports et je rêve d'un
matin on se sont exprimés à l'issue de
cette conférence de presse il s'agit
principalement d'une mauvaise gestion
des supporters britanniques muni en
partie de faux billets qui a provoqué
ces débordements est-ce qu'on peut
uniquement reporter la faute sur les
supporters britanniques
si je peux vous faire une confidence
j'étais très en colère hier soir sous ce
sujet parce que alors qu'on a donné une
très mauvaise image de la france et de
ses capacités d'organisation
d'aucuns essayer de reporter la faute
les uns sur les autres or c'est pas des
coupables il faut trouver des solutions
ou c'est pas se dédouaner qu'il faut
essayer de comprendre les
responsabilités aussi il faut comprendre
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres sauf que chacun les connaît il ya
eu une grève d'un rer qui a déjà mis
tout le monde en difficulté il faudra en
tirer les conséquences pour les
événements à venir il faut que le
dialogue social vives au sein de la ratp
au sein de la sncf parce qu'on voit bien
que on aurait pu y aura des morts hier
soir c'est ça qui aurait pu arriver au
delà même de l'image de la france aurait
pu voir des morts sur le terrain ensuite
il ya le le premier filtrage cas pas pu
fonctionner et pour cause puisque tout
le monde arrivé en même temps en tout
cas parler même cheminement ensuite il
ya eu effectivement ce problème de
billets puisque l'uefa a accepté que des
billets papier au lieu d'avoir des
billets seulement électroniques qui sont
moins falsifiable et enfin il ya eu de
la délinquance qui voyant le désordre
généralisé on a eu des délinquants venus
des cités marine le pen a accusé des
bandes de voyous de seine-saint-denis
et débordements eric zemmour dénonce les
racailles aussi du département de
seine-saint-denis
non mais chacun chacun essaye de
projeter ses propres obsessions le sujet
moi je pense qu'il faut trouver des
solutions pour que ça ne se reproduise
pas et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
gouvernement a bien fait de convoquer
une réunion en urgence et mettant tout
le monde autour de la table on n'a pas
vu arriver les hordes du grand
remplacement
sur le sur le terrain à la à côté du
stade de france on a vu comme d'habitude
200 à 300 jeunes délinquants venir
puisque voyant le désordre ils se sont
dit que c'était l'occasion de ici piquer
un portable ici piquer un billet mais on
connaît ça malheureusement presque tous
les dimanches en france dans les matchs
de village vous en avez deux ou trois
délinquants qui avait tout le monde et
puis dans les matchs de niveau régional
vous en avez 30 et puis dans les matchs
de niveau national ou international
commis hier vous en avez 300 dans ce cas
là la police et répondent parce que nous
avons réglé cette question depuis
désormais plusieurs années et on sait
les appréhender et on sait ensuite les
amener devant les juges si faire une
dissidente de ce point de vue là c'est
mieux dans ce cas là de les condamner
notamment de l'éloignement des stades et
des enceintes sportives plutôt qu'à des
stages de citoyenneté je ferme la
parenthèse
mais nous savons gérer ça et en
l'occurrence la police et du mal à le
gérer parce que effectivement auparavant
l'ensemble des filtrages n'avait pas
fonctionné justement question sur la
police et ce cas pas là un déni du
gouvernement sur les responsabilités
policière jean-luc mélenchon a mis en
cause la doctrine de l'emploi de là
police alors que des centaines de
supporters ont été gazés à la une de la
presse britannique un enfant de 9 ans a
été gazé des familles étaient là il ya
eu des matraques haussier sur des
personnes qui étaient en terrasse oui
mais vous venez de résumer en quelques
phrases la vie politique française
d'aujourd'hui
madame le pen et monsieur zemmour
explique que tout ça c'est la faute des
racailles et monsieur mélenchon explique
que tout ça c'est la faute de la police
moi je dis et c'est la position du
gouvernement et je le soutiens en cela
que face à un problème on regarde d'où
sont venus les désordres comment les
règles et comment ça ne se reproduit pas
là on voit bien qu'il ya eu une
accumulation de 4 ou 5 des ordres pour
conduire à quelque chose mais l'argent
n'est pas un problème de sous-effectif
au dos aux anticipations on voit qu'il
ya eu trente à quarante mille faux
billets ou un problème dans les services
de renseignement
six mille policiers lors
qu'habituellement ils sont 1200 autour
du stade de france donc je pense que
c'était suffisamment dimensionné mais
évidemment
le premier filtrage n'a pas pu se faire
dans de bonnes conditions et que
personne ne s'attendait à ce que les
40000 anglais qui venait en plus des
supporters munis de billets allait aussi
venir aux abords du stade de france
alors vous le savez c'est l'ouverture de
la campagne officielle aujourd'hui pour
les élections législatives et le premier
tour qui se tiendra le 12 juin prochain
on a beaucoup entendu jean luc mélenchon
dire qu'il serait premier ministre
élisez moi at-il dit déjà entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
voilà la majorité fait profil bas est ce
que vous me manquez pas un peu d'élan
pour ces élections
écoutez je crois pas en tout cas on a
effectivement pas les mêmes formes de
vociférations que jean luc mélenchon
pour autant le président de la
république a fixés
une ligne d'ambition et tout le travail
de la majorité c'est de la porter sur le
terrain pour espérer pouvoir la porter
ensuite à l'assemblée nationale et quel
est l'enjeu
il est presque aussi important qu'au
lendemain de la crise de 29 ce qu'a
proposé emmanuel macron lors de
l'élection présidentielle je crois qu'on
l'a pas suffisamment souligné c'est
l'équivalent du new deal de roosevelt ce
que nous avons fait pendant la crise en
soutenant l'économie ce qui nous a faits
au lendemain de la crise avec le plan de
soutien à l'économie ce que nous faisons
avec france 2030 la relocalisation
industrielle
les investissements en matière
écologique est ce que là nous proposons
en matière de pouvoir d'achat aussi bien
pour les retraités que pour la fonction
publique que pour les minima sociaux que
pour les salariés du privé c'est un
changement de paradigme c'est un
changement de société et donc c'est ça
qui nous faut porter sur le terrain
alors c'est peut-être
moins spectaculaire que le mariage forcé
ou l'alliance contre nature qui a essayé
de mettre en place jean luc mélenchon
mais on sait que tout ça de toute façon
ces désunions à durée déterminée
demain aux responsabilités il faudra
répondre aux inquiétudes des français on
l'a évoqué avec l'ukraine mais dans une
société qui va devenir celle du plein
emploi ça va être notre combat de tous
les jours et celle de l'inflation il
faut qu'on apporte des réponses pour
l'avenir
jean luc mélenchon bouge un peu plus moi
j'ai le sentiment qu'il apporte des
réponses à des questions du passé vous
pensez que ce sera un vote amplification
comme en 2010 est pour la majorité moi
je pense sera un vote très différent de
2017 en 2017 c'était un peu comme en
2012 en faveur de françois hollande ou
en 2007 en faveur de nicolas sarkozy
c'était effectivement un vote de
répliques au sens technique du terme là
je crois pas que ce sera ce soit le cas
on a un président de la république qui a
été réélu
mais il n'a pas été réélu seulement pour
lui-même il a été répondu réélu parce
que le la société et le monde était en
train de changer
il l'a redit d'ailleurs très bien lors
de sa cérémonie d'investiture
c'est pas lui qui a changé c'est pas
nous qui avons changé c'est le monde qui
a changé et que la france a changé
également
quand on se retrouve parce qu'on a
vaincu le chômage de masse des vues plus
personne ne parle du chômage dans cette
élection on a vécu le chômage de masse
on va aller vers la société du plein
emploi on se retrouve dans une forme de
démondialisation mais c'est intéressant
lorsque vous êtes sur la reprise
économique et une forte reprise
économique au lendemain et puis
aujourd'hui dans une forme de
démondialisation parce qu'à la fois la
crise sanitaire et la crise ukrainiennes
ont ralenti les échanges internationaux
et donc on va se trouver dans cette
société où on a à la fois une faible
croissance et beaucoup d'inflation et
donc la question du partage de la valeur
pour augmenter les salaires pour
s'adapter à l'inflation c'est un
changement de doctrine économique majeur
et on va en parler dans un tout petit
instant parce qu on a reparlé du pouvoir
d'achat avec tam tran huy on n'est plus
dans sa vie politique
on est dans un débat de société ça va
être ça le long jeu des élections
législatives alors patrick mignola je
propose qu'on prenne la direction du
figaro pour retrouver notre partenaire
et vincent roux qui est en duplex
bonsoir vincent vous gpec delà de la
rédaction du figaro l'aviez vous aviez
une question sur le pass vaccinale pour
notre invité oui puisqu'on parle des
débats des questions de société patrick
mignola il ya une question de société
qui a été soulevée finalement il ya
quelques semaines il ya quelques mois
par à nos collègues à l'assemblée à
l'assemblée de la majorité
présidentielle même s'il est l omc
julien moreau vix qui avait déclaré je
ne vois pas comment on peut maintenir le
pass vaccinale au delà du 31 juillet
2022 31 juillet 2022 parce que c'est la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui a
été votée au mois de janvier dernier
quelle est votre position quelle sera la
position du modem à ce moment là est-ce
qu'il faut prolonger l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est ce qu'il faut prolonger le
pass vaccinale selon vous savez qu'on a
eu à s'exprimer à plusieurs reprises sur
les questions de délais et notamment le
groupe que je préside le groupe modem a
été très sourcilleux sur la question de
la fixation de ces dates moi je pense
que le 31 juillet est une bonne date
d'ici là
il ya que trois choses qui doivent
présider à notre réflexion la science la
science patience
ça veut dire la science qu'elle sera
le niveau pandémique dans la société
est ce que demain on peut pas imaginer
que on aura un nouveau variant est donc
il serait absolument nécessaire en
particulier pour les plus fragiles dans
la société continue à l'automne il
faudrait vacciner cette vaccination
exactement moi je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention à ça ça essayez si demain
grâce à la vaccination il ya moins de
complications sanitaires tant mieux
l'elysée prolongé bien il ya sanitaires
mais comme je vous le dis et vient par
préférence par choix politique par
engagement du groupe modem nous voulons
éviter tous les régimes d'exception qui
sont privatives de libertés publiques
mais moi je ne peux pas dire aujourd'hui
nul à mais moi je ne peux pas dire
aujourd'hui ce que sera la situation
sanitaire au 31 juillet parce que sinon
je vous mange fait de la démagogie et je
dirai tout ce qu'elle soit le pass
vaccinale qu'on va l'enlever et c'est
pas ma responsabilité à 100 quel sera le
curseur quel sera le curseur alors à
quel niveau le curseur c'est comme on
l'a fait depuis le début de la pandémie
vous savez à quel point ça a été
difficile parfois de prendre des
décisions de cet ordre là qui étaient
privatives de libertés publiques c'est
le niveau pandémique
c'est l'avis de la haute autorité de
santé c'est avec comme horizon
principal ultime obligatoire la
protection des plus fragiles dans le
pays et à partir de là si au 31 juillet
on a la possibilité de lever l'état
d'urgence sanitaire évidemment le lèvera
la décision vous la prenez quand puisque
c'est le 31 juillet de toute façon on
aura à prendre une décision dans les
trois semaines qui précèdent j'invite
donc d'ailleurs à bien bien observer ce
que pourrait être une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale qui a été plus
qu'ambiguë
s'il s'agissait de nu baisse de la
france insoumise de jean luc mélenchon
sur les questions du pass vaccinale
entendu merci pour
votre réponse merci à vous traitera nuit
pour public sénat clément méric dès le
cp nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau etc
vous tam qui ai commencé à interroger
patrick mignola sur les mesures de
pouvoir d'achat rio ribout reçoit
patrick mignola effectivement vous avez
commencé à parler du pouvoir d'achat
c'est la première priorité des français
pendant la campagne présidentielle
pendant cette campagne des législatives
on connaît beaucoup des mesures du
paquet du point d'achat qui va être
présenté alors pourquoi attendre après
les législatives pour les présentait
justement ces mesures en conseil des
ministres parce qu'il faut savoir
expliquer aux français que ces mesures
coûteront de l'argent vous avez raison
au fond ça pourrait être réglementaire
s'est pas seulement du législatif mais
il ya aussi du budgétaire et il faudra
que au même moment que nous présentons
les mesures de pouvoir d'achat nous
présentions une rectification du budget
la tient pour choeur on augmente pas aux
français mais si on avait quand même ces
mesures de façon beaucoup plus clair
aujourd'hui ne serait ce pas beaucoup
plus simple pour vous de faire campagne
sur toutes ces mesures qui sont en moi
je pense qu populaire pour les français
sont extrêmement claires d'abord voulait
pas voir le débat et les oppositions
maintenant on prend pas de mesures on
prend pas de mesure seulement pour être
populaire on prend des mesures parce que
c'est nécessaire et à président de la
république lui même été très clair
pendant la campagne présidentielle on
indexe les pensions de retraite sur
l'inflation on débloque le point
d'indicé de la fonction publique pour
s'adapter aussi à l'inflation
conséquemment on le fait aussi pour les
minima sociaux parce que sont les
personnes les plus fragiles dans la
société qui souffre de l'inflation
aujourd'hui et on triple la prime
pouvoir d'achat pour que les salariés du
privé puissent partout où c'est possible
dans les entreprises privées accompagné
aussi l'échelle de l'inflation alors
vous dites mais les gagner mais
immédiatement rebouc le ça et c'est là
que c'est très important par de grandes
lois à passer pendant l'été sur la
participation l'intéressement
l'actionnariat salarié ça sera dans leur
projet parce qu'il n'est pas possible
non ce sera une deuxième loi parce que
tu as il faut qu'on le fasse dans le
cadre d'une deuxième hall la première
loi d'urgence triplé la prime macron et
ensuite il faut que dans toutes les
entreprises on facilite un meilleur
partage de la valeur ou sabine depuis 20
ans on a plus rémunérer le capital que
le travail dans notre pays
dans ses passions ça se décide par une
loi et que ce dès le mois de juillet
exactement pour faciliter pour faciliter
un meilleur partage de la valeur c'est
très important je rappelais tout à
l'heure qu'on allait dans une société de
l'inflation mais d'une croissance plus
faible que celle qu'on attendait et donc
la question d'un meilleur partage de la
valeur ou quand une entreprise donne un
dividende à un actionnaire elle donne
aussi un dividende un salarié c'est
fondamental aussi en terme de projet de
société justement sur l'inflation il ya
donc une inflation notamment des
distributeurs alimentaires ça va
augmenter de vie pour cent vous dit que
tout est très clair sur ce texte le
montant de chaque alimentation ça le
connaît non justement ils sont en train
de le regarder et pourquoi donc on le
connaît pas donc ça me met pas tout
n'est pas le débat
1er juillet ado c'est pour ça donc ça
sera indexée sur l'inflation et il ya
des réponses extrêmement simple quand
vous quand vous dites que vous indexé
une politique sur l'inflation c'est un
changement énorme nos parents nos grands
parents avaient vécu dans une société de
l'inflation mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'avoir
une conférence permanente sur les prix
et sur les salaires c'est moi j'avais
appelé à une conférence nationale sur
les salaires ouverte au dialogue social
avec l'ensemble des syndicats
représentait-il tant pis c'est
extrêmement important et il faut qu'on
ait le même type d'observation pour
s'adapter à l'inflation et aujourd'hui
on nous dit ça peut être peut-être être
10% sur l'alimentation bon moi j'ai
entendu certains de nos concurrents qui
disent on va bloquer les prix ont ils
donné mais est ce que demande de l'année
ps jean luc mélenchon il annule ps
propose de blu ray
edwards et donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer si on bloque les prix on va créer
de la pénurie on créera encore plus
d'inflation et qu'est ce qui va se
passer chez la grande distribution moi
je vous le dit d' avance ils feront
mourir les petits exploitants agricoles
parce que pour bloquer les primes et
maintenir ses marges et bassetto aux
producteurs qu'on le fera payer dire
c'est michel edouard leclerc en a rêvé
jean luc mélenchon veut le faire il y
avait le généraliser le shaq
alimentation
je leur disais le généraliser parce que
pour l'instant effectivement ça sera
prévu pour les plus précaires les plus
modestes si on arrive à une inflation de
8 10% sur l'alimentation ça va
coucou pétrole il faut pas voir ça
qu'ils ont besoin démagogue sur ces
sujets là il faut que ce soit pour les
plus précaires et qu'on ouvre très
largement pour les classes moyennes
parce que 1,1 des
uns des malheurs notre société j'allais
lire un des cancers de notre société
c'est la façon dont elle traite ses
classes moyennes les gens qui
travaillent et qui s'en sortent pas les
gens qui travaillent qui gagne toujours
trop pour avoir des aides mais jamais
assez pour vivre comme il faut donc à
combien ont besoin de chaque habitation
c'est ce que je viens de vous décrire je
sais si je voudrais bien que mon
énumération
valeur de vous ennuyer un peu mais je
n'ai pas dit que je vous ai dit offrir
les salaires de la fonction publique
les salariés du privé les pensions de
retraites si on s'adapte à l'inflation
là on a tout cette france qui
travaillent ou qui a travaillé qui va
pouvoir avoir un pouvoir d'achat
permettant de s'adapter à l'inflation en
revanche la question de ceux qui sont
tout en bas de l'échelle c'est
complètement différent parce que une
augmentation de 12% du prix des pâtes de
12% du prix des beliebers de 8% de des
légumes frais ou des fruits c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose quand vous
touchez 880 euros par mois et quand vous
touchez de 1500 euros par mois à 2500
euros par mois il faut que l'on puisse
augmenter les salaires et c'est ça la
vision que nous portons dans la société
dire que globalement au fur et à mesure
que l'inflation augmente il faut qu'on
puisse augmenter les salaires du public
et du privé pour s'adapter à l'inflation
mais en revanche on sait que l'inflation
fait d'abord souffrir les plus fragiles
et c'est à ça que sert le chèque
alimentation après un un mot simplement
il faut que le chèque alimentation
permet aussi de faire muter notre
appareil agroalimentaire et donc ceci
local du du local bio
du respectueux de l'environnement de la
biodiversité du bien-être animal qui
évite les polluants le les intrants et
le chèque alimentation
sociale de leur pouvoir d'achat patrick
mignola
sur le gaz ou l'électricité alors il va
être prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
bruno le maire a réaffirmé aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y aura pas de rattrapage sur la
facture d'électricité des français
sauf qu'il ya quand même un manque à
gagner pour les fournisseurs
d'électricité qui va falloir compenser
alors qui va payer et c'est pour ça que
je vous dis que parce qu'on essaye de
dire la vérité aux français et qu'on va
pas raser gratis il faut qu'au moment où
on prolonge le bouclier tarifaire au
moment où on fait le chèque alimentation
y ait un projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour qu'on inscrive dans ce
projet de loi de finances que c'est bien
l'état l'argent public qui comprend
allait passer c'est un peu un tour de
passe passe est venu annoncer si c'est
pas sur la facture des clients
les impôts payés par les contribuables
et donc vous observez que comme on
n'augmente pas les impôts ça voudra dire
faire des efforts par ailleurs ailleurs
évidemment évidemment c'est le il n'y a
pas de magie ya jamais de miracle en
matière budgétaire ça veut dire que
forcément on devrait être si on veut
tenir un bon niveau d'équilibré des
finances publiques et qu'on fait pas
payer la facture aux français ni par
l'augmentation de l'énergie ni par
l'augmentation des impôts il faudra que
par ailleurs en effet on fasse des
efforts en face notamment vous avez des
vous avez des pistes avait qu un mirage
aujourd'hui on est au domaine on est
obligé de faire du décalage budgétaire
sur un certain nombre d'investissements
on voit bien comment ça va se présenter
l'enjeu en réalité
pour les deux à trois exercices
budgétaires qui viennent ça va être
l'enjeu du plein emploi parce que si on
est capable de réussir le plein emploi
et que ainsi on ramène plus de
ressources fiscales et plus de
ressources sociales dans le budget de
l'état on pourra s'en sortir parce qu'il
est évidemment pas question de ne pas
tenir notre parole sur le ségur ne pas
permettre d'embaucher plus de monde dans
le secteur médico-social et dans les
ehpad et dans les maisons de retraite et
que
l'assurance-chômage aussi oui bien sûr
mais ça irait on semble c'est sur
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui je pense
que la première ministre a raison
de temporiser un peu pour discuter avec
les syndicats de salariés parce qu'on
rentre dans une société du plein emploi
on va avoir besoin à nouveau 2 voir les
règles de l'assurance chômage le
principe est simple
les règles d'assurance chômage quand la
société est en difficulté économique
elles doivent être assouplies et en
revanche quand on a une société
économique qui va mieux by fait qu'il en
faut qu'on soit plus exigeants en
matière d'assurance chômage dans une
vision très simple sur l'assurance
chômage c'est ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés de l'emploi on doit les
indemniser plus et plus longtemps parce
qu'il leur faut plus de temps pour
revenir sur le marché de l'emploi en
revanche ceux qui sont près de l'emploi
qui pourrait retravailler il ya aucune
raison qui reste deux mois ou trois mois
de plus au chômage alors qui a des
besoins dans le btp dans l'hôtellerie
dans le restaurant social
pour s'occuper des durées le montant la
location on réduira le temps seulement
moi je crois qu'il ya vraiment une
question de temps
aujourd'hui le des personnes qui sont
très éloignées de l'emploi parfois j'ai
pas peur de le dire même si c'est pas
populaire parfois parce qu'ils sont
fragiles il ya besoin de les indemniser
pendant plus de 18 mois parce qu'il faut
vraiment les faire remonter dans le
train de de l'insertion dans la société
c'est extrêmement important on leur doit
plus d'accompagnement pour qu'ils aient
une deuxième chance ou une troisième
chance dans la vie en revanche celui qui
peut travailler il n'y a aucune raison
qui ils attendent un peu plus et je ne
fais pas de caricature je fais pas de
démagogie là-dessus dire mais assez
logiquement si vous voulez rester quatre
mois au chômage n'y a pas de raison que
vous restiez pas quatre mois revenir sur
le bouclier tarifaires et sur ses
conséquences ça fragilise un peu plus
edf qui était déjà dans une situation
financière très délicate avec une
production d'électricité en forte baisse
cette année avec des surcoûts des
dépassements de coûts sur les lieux prs
que vous êtes favorable à une
renationalisation totale d'edf peut-être
pour l'aider à mener à bien les
chantiers des futures centrales
nucléaires françaises vous pouvez
éventuellement recapitaliser edf mais
pas nécessairement renationaliser on est
effectivement devenu situation difficile
vous le dites non vous était pas
favorable à une
vous avez un élément qui est très
important sur edf c'est sa capacité
d'investissement sur les nouveaux outils
ni clair sur lequel président de la
république s'est engagé et le nous vous
utile et drôle électrique pour moi qui
suis un
lui des montagnes voyez bien le l'enjeu
que les barrages restent
sous entreprises publiques voilà que
jamais on puisse les ouvrir à la
concurrence et que demain ce soient des
investisseurs étrangers qui en
détiennent tout ou partie savon du quai
voltaire les barrages ou aussi pour
l'ensemble du renouvelable l'éolien le
solaire il ya une filiale d'edf qui est
derrière moi qui ai voté à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la loi sur la
prolongation du service public de la
compagnie nationale du rhône c'est moi
qui les portaient devant que voilà
j'espère bien portait exactement le même
type de loi ça les barrages je crois
qu'il faut définir dans tous les métiers
d'edf ce qui relève de
l'indépendance stratégique du pays et ça
ça doit rester intégralement publics et
s'il le faut nationaliser et puis il ya
d'autres métiers qui sont des métiers
qui sont ouverts à la concurrence lequel
edf a des vraies qualités en cinquième
il faut qu'il continue impact sur
l'exportation d'électricité sur la
distribution d'électricité dira t il ya
des vraies qualités d'edf il ya aussi
des capacités sur la construction de
deux nouvelles centrales parce que
demain si vous voulez faire d'hydrogène
vert il va bien falloir se
s'appuyer sur des compétences très
importantes à l'intérieur d'edf et
parfois ils pourront avoir intérêt
intérêt à venir sur le marché
concurrentiel parce qu'ils remporteront
des marchands que ce qu'on comprend en
tout cas recapitalisation we re
nationalisation
pas forcément
c'est une évidence pour moi le nucléaire
l'hydroélectricité c'est évidemment
publique et nationale sur d'autres
métiers ça peut être l'intérêt d'edf
la cfdt réclame +2 3% et le modem vous
voulez combien
sur le dégel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
ont dit qu'on s'adapte à l'inflation on
n'est pas dans une compet vous voyez la
cfdt
s'accroît du mois de quoi de 2 mai deux
jours c'est 5,4
et moi je pense que il faut que le
l'ensemble de la représentation
syndicale travail avec la première
ministre pour déterminer ce que doit
être le dégel de points du point
d'indicé et nous ensuite pour le coup on
en tirera les conséquences à l'assemblée
nationale pour mettre les budgets qui
vont en face mais s'est à plusieurs
reprises en question mais c'est quoi le
bon chiffre de la rumba et des retraites
et puis c'est quoi le bon chiffre de le
du déblocage du port ne disent mais le
bon chiffre c'est celui qui s'adapte à
l'inflation
ce qu'elle faisait les derniers chiffres
de l'inflation c'est la moyenne des six
derniers mois non mais comment ça se
calcule et et comment vous faites pour
les cadres de catégorie c c'est à dire
ceux qui touchent le moins dans les
collectivités locales moi je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit supérieur donc voila
vous donc en fait je vais pas vous en
servir parce que si je vous dis 3 %
alors qu'en réalité il faudra mettre 4,2
et en fait il faudrait plutôt mettre 4 5
ou 4,8 pour les cadres de catégorie c
est bien ça bien c'est on vous dit
c'est un new deal dans la société
française on va vers la société du plein
emploi et de l'inflation ce qu'a donné
comme ambition emmanuel macron c'est un
new deal à la roosevelt où on est
capable de relancer le pouvoir d'achat
de relancer la relocalisation
industrielle dans le pays et la
planification énergétique dans des
conditions qu'on n'avait jamais vécu
secrètement c'est pas le même chiffre
pour tout le monde
ça c'est le travail des cinq laisser
travailler la conservation pour le goji
aussi oui on n'a
pas suffisamment de dialogue social dans
ce pays et donc c'est sûrement pas un
parlementaire moi je suis très favorable
à ce qu'il y a un bien meilleur dialogue
entre le gouvernement et le parlement je
n'ai aucun problème avec ça mais en
revanche quand ça concerne les salariés
et en particulier sa la république
laisser travailler le gouvernement et
les syndicats juste une dernière
question sur la réindexation des
retraites donc ça va avoir lieu au mois
d'août est-ce que s'il ya encore
toujours cette inflation au mois de
janvier prochain une nouvelle hausse des
pensions de retraite c'est exactement ce
que je décrivais tout à l'heure quand
vous entrez dans une société durablement
inflationnistes c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui au fond ne fait complètement différé
du programme porté par jean luc
mélenchon iriti blocage des prix comme
si on était rentrés dans un moment
inflationnistes pour trois mois ou pour
un an en réalité on va voir une décennie
inflationnistes c'est ça qui est devant
nous et donc comme dans les années 50 60
70 ce même le début des années 80 il
faut qu'on ait à période régulière la
capacité d'ajuster toutes les pensions
fixe les pensions de retraite les minima
sociaux on parlait à l'instant de la
fonction publique c'est exactement ce
sujet là on a besoin dans ce pays
d'avoir une conférence nationale
permanente sur les rémunérations
de 1000 euros c'est bien code à chaque
fois en fait on essaye de ne pas adapter
les pensions de retraite celle de madame
bettencourt
on est bien d'accord mais si vous voulez
de l'argent mais mme bettencourt oui
vous êtes vous êtes favorable à un
meilleur dialogue entre le parlement et
le gouvernement est ce que vous même le
modem vous avez des mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat que vous comptez portée
lors du débat parlementaire qui va
s'ouvrir dans quelques semaines on a eu
une demande particulière jeu j'en
parlais à l'instant sur le les cadres de
catégorie c dans la fonction publique je
pense en particulier dans la fonction
publique territoriale où on a salué à
raison les soignants on a salué et à
raison
les personnels dans les services fiscaux
ou dans les services de sécurité
je pense qu'on a trop peu penser aux
personnels qui étaient les petits
salaires de la fonction publique dans
les mairies et donc dans les
départements vous souhaitez paris dont
on souhaite c'est quasiment un pouce
pour em en terre parce que forcément
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
quand vous êtes vraiment au bas de
l'échelle des salaires c'est là que vous
souffrez le plus des à-coups d'inflation
et vous êtes en accord avec le reste de
la majorité là dessus il ya vous en
effet porté par le modem et puis après
on dit cela dans la majorité
on peut avoir des discussions on peut
avoir des exigences et je crois qu'on a
en tout cas plus de cohérence que la du
ps sur notre capacité à gérer
l'assemblée nationale ensemble à léopard
les retraites à table oui la retraite à
65 ans on n'entend pas beaucoup parler
la concertation va donc commencer
seulement en septembre est ce que c'est
un dossier que vous ne voulez pas vous
traîner pendant la campagne législative
un boulet pas du tout alors on en parle
est
enterrée mais non mais vous vous voyez
bien il n'y a pas
un français de bonne foi qu'ils
imaginent alors qu'on vit quinze ans de
plus qu'en 1981 qu' on puisse pas
discuter d'une réforme des retraites ça
c'est bien 19
15 ans de moins qu'aujourd'hui et on
partait à la retraite à 65 ans elle est
nécessaire secteur de l'équilibré la
retraite est ce qu'elle est nécessaire
pour équilibrer le système de choses et
après je vais vous dire comment on peut
peut-être travailler à un consensus est
nécessaire pour deux choses équilibrer
le système des retraites parce que moi
je veux pas être la première génération
de parlementaires qui sera pas capable
de servir les pensions de nos parents et
nos grands parents qui brigue un
deuxième chose le concernant
servir le corps
il se trouve qu'en 2017
quand j'ai été élu pour la première fois
comme député le corps avait dit qu'il
n'y avait pas de problème avec le
financement des retraites q en 2018 le
cor a publié un autre rapport disant
qu'il ya un problème de financement
du corps si vous voulez bien moi je vous
ai dit deux choses mais on y dit
n'importe quoi le corps pour vous vous
ne le croyez pas lorsqu'il dit les
dépenses de retraites vont baisser à 11%
du pib en 2000 constat l'un des plus bas
niveau en europe que le cours a dit une
chose et l' inverse entre 2017 et 2018
quand on est député et qu'on doit
prendre des décisions dans ce cas là
c'est pas très facile de s'appuyer sur
quelqu'un qui dit une chose l inverse en
un an voilà ce que je dis moi je porte
pas de jugement de valeur je fais
deuxième chose si vous voulez bien me
laisser terminer la réforme des
retraites elle est nécessaire pour
financer la dépendance
un problème orpea et c'est oublier
qu'aujourd'hui on a dit on a des
difficultés
et donc de financer la dépendance n'est
pas les retraites qui finance la
dépendance c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche c'est que aujourd'hui si vous
n'équilibre est pas le régime des
retraites et on sait depuis 1992
corrompent accord depuis michel rocard
depuis 1992 on sait qu'en entre 2032 et
2035 on aurait une difficulté à
équilibrer le régime il ya tout
simplement parce qu'en 1992 on savait
qu'elles étaient les bébés qui avaient
20 ans à ce moment là et qu'ils allaient
rentrer sur le marché du travail j'en
fais partie et on savait qu'elles
étaient les générations qu'elle ait pu
séparer de partir à la retraite et donc
on sait qu'entre 2032 et 2035 y aura un
problème il se trouve que cette
assemblée devait être élu en 2022
jusqu'en 2027 si on n'est pas capable de
prendre des décisions en 2027 pour un
problème dont on sait depuis
vous savez
c'est pourquoi c'est parce que ce qui va
déterminer l'âge in fine et c'est les
progrès sociaux qu'on veut mettre dans
cette réforme qu'est ce qu'on fait en
matière de pénibilité qu'est ce qu'on
fait en matière de carrière longue
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière de
formation tout au long de la vie parce
que les générations qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail ils vont avoir trois
ou quatre métiers différents et si
possible de moins en moins pénible au
cours de leur vie qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour l'emploi des seniors parce que
c'est une des grandes difficultés du
marché du travail en france et enfin
comment on traite la question de la
transmission en fin de carrière ou sur
les dernières années où on va travailler
on va travailler un peu moins et
transmettre un peu plus aux générations
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
dans une économie de compétences comme
l'économie française tout ça c'est des
progrès sociaux très importants parce
que tout le monde est complètement
obsédé sur la sphère de la jeunesse très
important la jeun savoir si on va partir
dix-huit mois avant 18 mois après dans
certains médias
mais met immédiatement c'est devenu un
totem emmanuel macron quand il a parlé
vous étiez à sa conférence de presse
quand il a parlé du sujet de la retraite
il a parlé de tous ces sujets là elle
dit comment on remet des progrès sociaux
dans la façon de travailler est dans la
façon de partir à la retraite tous ces
progrès sociaux ils ont un coût et alors
on discutera pour financer ces progrès
sociaux qui l'a beaucoup sont
directement liés au travail directement
lié à la difficulté du travail
à quel âge on partira elisabeth borgne a
évidemment raison de dire ben entre 64
et 65 oui si on veut pas mettre de
progrès sociaux peut-être qu'on dira 64
ça suffit si on veut mettre des progrès
sociaux peut-être qu'il faudra aller à
65 ben moi je préfère travailler jusqu'à
65 ans parce que j'ai pas un métier
pénible
mais financer le 2e meilleur ehpad pour
nos grands-parents et financé des vrais
progrès sociaux pour ceux qui sont au
bas de l'échelle sociale dans ce pays
d'un mot juste olivier grégoire le porte
parole du gouvernement a promis de mener
cette réforme sans brutalité est ce que
ça veut dire 149,3 à vos yeux est ce que
le modem s'opposerait à l'utilisation du
49-3 cas de ce débat c'est
malheureusement pas comme ça mais vous
le savez monsieur mairie que c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe qu'en fait on
peut pas s'opposer 1 49 3 points peut
éventuellement est ce que vous pouvez
refuser
faire une chose d'abord c'est se donner
le temps de travailler surtout les
progrès sociaux que je viens de liste et
parce que là dessus il ya du grain à
moudre comme on le dit parfois dans les
discussions avec la corne
d'abondance habilité sur un âge on sait
qu'il ya une loi qui est en cours il
faut probablement le la modifier parce
que ça il faut dire la vérité aux
français c'est il ya que comme ça qu'on
s'en sortira ensuite ce que je pense
qu'il faut pas procéder comme on l'avait
fait la dernière fois c'est à dire que
commander déposé le texte un peu tard il
n'y avait pas pu avoir de temps
législatif programmé donc tout le monde
était parti dans une très grande
créativité d'amendements qui n'avait ni
queue ni tête moi j'y suis resté jour et
nuit pendant trois semaines et pendant
trois semaines
on est arrivé au 43 je pense que là si
on présente bien la réforme en amont on
n'aura pas besoin d'avocat une question
sur la pénurie à martin hirsch
aujourd'hui qui a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé à manque 1400 infirmiers rien
qu'en ile-de-france y aussi patrick peu
loin qui nous dit déjà nous avertit des
services en ti vont fermer cet été c'est
à dire demain qu'est ce que vous
proposez il ya un manque de lure
plusieurs centaines williams ont déjà on
voit des d'aider les urgences avaient
retenti dans le panier du dans le cadre
de ce new deal dont je parlais tout à
l'heure on doit être capable d'adapter
les salaires à l'inflation et aux
besoins de la société
ce que je vois c'est qu'il faut creuser
à dire j'allais vous répondre maintenant
tout de suite vous dire c'est on a
besoin de creuser deux choses comment on
rémunère mieux les nuits comme on
rémunère mieux les week-ends ce que la
question là c'est juillet août comment
on va passer juillet avec des soignants
qui ont besoin de vacances parce qu'ils
ont le droit d'être fatigué bien
légitime un certain nombre d'entre eux
qui
un peu écoeuré de la situation qui vient
de se dérouler pendant deux ans vu une
telle crise c'est difficile en cas de
démission il assis dans les stands et
bifurquer
ceci étant aggravée par soit dans les
grandes villes les difficultés à se
loger parce que les salaires sont trop
bas malgré le ségur de la santé on a
encore des salaires qui sont trop bas
pour se loger à paris par exemple mais
c'est la même chose à lyon à bordeaux à
strasbourg - on augmente les salaires
mais en général et
de choses à faire moi je crois qu'il ya
la question des primes de nuit et des
primes de week-end
en fait c'est débloqué un budget
spécifique ça rend dans les projets de
loi de finances rectificative herminis
tout à l'heure devant les parlementaires
de la majorité nous annoncer qu'elle
avait demandé à brigitte bourguignon de
travailler sur ces sujets moi ça peut
faire partie
exactement moi je pense que dès le mois
de juin la nouvelle majorité qui sortira
des urnes j'espère que les élections
nous seront favorables nous pourrions
proposer une augmentation des budgets
dans chaque hôpital pour pouvoir
augmenter les nuits et les week-ends
deuxième chose mieux travaillé que la
médecine de ville il faut que ce soit
fait beaucoup plus dans la concertation
que
parce que ça a été fait un peu dans la
précipitation au cours des derniers
jours la troisième chose c'est aussi la
question des conditions de travail parce
que je croyais bien que
il ya aussi à organiser dans les
services en faisant confiance au terrain
il ya 30 des initiatives pour que les
gens se sentent mis aussi parce qu'il ya
des endroits où on a augmenté les
salaires on a augmenté les budgets des
hôpitaux où ils peuvent embaucher 10 ans
les moyens d'embaucher est embauché à
des bons salaires mais les gens ne
viennent pas parce qu'il ya aussi une
condition la baisse alors il ya un
problème justement c'est la dernière
question dans d'autres secteurs en
france et notamment dans la restauration
360 mille emplois non pourvus cet été
annonce lui émis h le principal syndicat
dans l'hôtellerie il en train de
négocier une convention avec la tunisie
pour faire venir des serveurs tunisien
peut-être dès cet été est-ce que vous
soutenez cette démarche ou est-ce que ça
vous choque mais
je pense que dans le secteur privé
chacun peut prendre les initiatives
qu'il veut
j'ai déjà bien qu'aboutisse une
négociation de branche dans le domaine
de l'hôtellerie tourisme
restauration mais sur
la négociation salue une augmentation de
salaire mais aujourd'hui la question du
statut
des week-ends des jours d'affilée où on
travaille avec l'espagne en finale il
n'y avait jamais eu de négociations cc
c'est six dans le new deal budgétaires
financiers salariale dont je parlais
tout à l'heure il peut y avoir aussi un
new deal social et que des secteurs
d'activité qui n'ont jamais entamé de
négociations sur les conditions de
travail pouvait le faire dire s'ils
doivent trouver des solutions à court
terme jeu qu'ils le fassent mais enfin
dans un pays qui a encore 7 % de
chômeurs on n'est pas au chômage
structurel
et ses 7 % c'est pas tous des feignants
et bat donné leur envie de travailler en
les payant mieux et en organisant mieux
les conditions de travail moi j'avais un
grand père qui était restaurateur vient
et quand on trouvait pas
dans les salons organisés me les
conditions de travail merci à mme tran
huy merci clément mérite d'avoir été
avec nous pour interroger patrick
mignola dans un instant c'est à yves
thréard qui va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau avant c'est une question sur la
proportionnelle on sait que c'est un
nouveau combat au modem est ce que vous
avez eu un accord ferme cette fois que
la proportionnelle s'offrait on se
souvient qu'en 2017 ça faisait partie de
l'accord de françois bayrou de son
ralliement à emmanuel macron et puis on
n'a pas eu la proportionnelle alors
c'est pourquoi le président de la
république s'est exprimé pendant la
campagne présidentielle sur ce sujet il
les dit très clairement d'ailleurs dans
un événement qui était à pau à côté de
françois bayrou donc je pense que
françois belloy bien entendu ce qu'il
avait dit en disant que sa préférence
personnelle était pour une
proportionnelle d'ailleurs
proportionnelle dit intègre alors pas
tout à fait intégral c'est que de
meilleurs projets de proportionnelle à
mes yeux c'est le projet qui était celui
de françois mitterrand en 1986 qui avait
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce qu'on dit
dégagé une majorité rpr udf à l'époque
c'est celui où on a une proportionnelle
départementale dans tous les
départements de france avec la même
règle et avec une distribution de sièges
à partir de 5 % moi je pense que ce
serait sage
et même que c'est obligatoire si on tire
pas les conséquences
des élections locales où il ya eu 30 %
de participation et d'une élection
présidentielle où il seulement 70% de
participation c'est qu'on n'a pas
compétence des ça chaque élection
rapidement par une loi simple au
lendemain des législatives
moi je prendrai toutes mes
responsabilités pour que aboutissent le
la proportionnelle au cours de cette
législature
je pense que s'il est bien une personne
en france qui est consciente des
difficultés de notre démocratie et de la
nécessité d'un nouveau pacte civique et
social ces manuels m il ferait arnaud a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir yves bon
sens vous et hésitent eux réalisent
directeur adjoint au figaro et vous
vouliez parler des législatives au liban
on va parler mais alors justement parce
que bonjour patrick mignola
vous êtes partis sur le la
proportionnelle je voudrais continuer un
tout petit peu si vous permettez sur les
institutions parce que c'était un des
grands chantiers du président de la
république sortant réélu et c'est un
chantier qui a été complètement laissé
tomber il ya une réforme
institutionnelle est ce que cette
réforme peut avoir lieu dans ce second
mandat la proportionnelle comme l'a dit
brigitte c'est une loi simple mais une
réforme ou eh bien on envisage le
référendum d'initiative populaire
citoyenne ou eh bien on ajoute quelques
mots sur l'écologie dans les premiers
dans les premiers articles enfin une
vraie réforme qui nécessite peut-être
lusage du référendum ce qui était prévu
d'ailleurs dans la réforme
constitutionnelle comportait qu'on n'a
pas pu faire aboutir dans le précédent
il ya effectivement les engagements
écologiques il doit en faire partie oui
il ya un élément important aussi sur le
l'évolution de l'autorité judiciaire oui
je pense qu'il ya un sujet fondamental
ce sujet de la différenciation parmi
ceux que vous ne vais pas citer
différenciation cet article soit 60
77 et 78
ans a déjà été votée mais
malheureusement on n'a pas pu aller au
bout de la réforme est donc aujourd'hui
si on les incitations faut qu'on
comprenne parce que c'est la
différenciation sur de la loi à des lois
dans les territoires c'est à dire que
les fondamentaux le régalien et les
grands équilibres économiques et sociaux
doivent rester nationaux c'est une
évidence mais souvent dans les
collectivités c'est selon qu'on est en
montagne ou selon qu'on est dans le
littoral selon qu'on est en métropole ou
selon que on est dans des espaces ruraux
l'application de la loi pourrait être un
peu différente c'est fondamental en
termes d'application de la loi et donc
le fait qu'on puisse avancer sur ce
sujet institutionnels ça peut nous
permettre d avancer outre-mer des
avancées corse et je pense que ça pourra
faire la satisfaction de beaucoup de
maires en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux parce que moi
j'aimerais bien que dans ce quinquennat
on vive pas à nouveau la guerre attisée
par les oppositions entre les villes et
les campagnes entre les métropoles et la
ruralité vous souhaitez donc que cette
réforme un stick constitutionnel ait
lieu oui dans ce message il faut le
faire dès le début du quinquennat
ce qu'on doit faire dès le début du
quinquennat c'est le sujet de pouvoir
d'achat c'est les grands chantiers de
écologie écoles et
ensuite si on peut le porter à
référendum mais vous savez qu'en matière
constitutionnelle
autant pour faire un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne président de la
république c'est s'est engagée à
abaisser le seuil et moi je suis
d'accord avec cette idée huit cent mille
citoyens ou 700000 vallerey pour porter
un élément à votation comme on dit en
suisse ça fonctionne très bien mais pour
arriver à soumettre à référendum une
réforme institutionnelle il faut que
assemblée et sénat vote dans les mêmes
termes article 89 de la consigne de
tiers et ensuite qu'on aille à
référendum d'accord aux deux tiers la
majorité c'est pas une majorité simple
que chacun vote et soit on fait le
congrès aux deux tiers des deux tiers en
congrès soit on fait un référendum alors
les législatives bouzid en parlait
grands sujets on en parle on en parle
non mais les français on parle très peu
d'ailleurs
vous savez comment vous avez du mal à
les réveiller à les intéresser surtout
moins vous avez de soixantaine de
députés aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
visez plus de députés dans la nouvelle
assemblée jeu j'aimerais beaucoup parce
qu'on a 107 candidats
qui travaillent sur le terrain en ce
moment et parmi lesquels il ya
des jeunes pousses parmi lesquels il ya
des gens qui représentent
qui représente la chair de la société
française j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils
accèdent effectivement à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui est important c'est
surtout ce qu'on va faire ensuite alors
moi j'ai confiance dans les candidats
qu'on présente au nom de
l'équipe mais notre objectif c'est
d'avoir déjà une majorité pour la
majorité ce que les choses
les choses ne sont pas gagnées est-ce
que vous aurez la majorité absolue c'est
le aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je ne
ressemblais attention oui ensemble
renaissance mouvement démocrate agir
agir horizons je ne sais pas si on aura
une majorité vous êtes à quai oui parce
que je sens même je crains des formes de
radicalisation et de violence dans le
débat public qui sont alimentées
notamment par jean-luc mélenchon par
jean luc mélenchon d'un côté et depuis
quelques jours ça y est on les a vus
revenir sur le terrain également par le
par l'extrême droite vous les avez
peut-être un petit peu aidé avec ce qui
s'est passé au stade de france moi je
j'aimerais alors je suis sûr qu'on en
ait voulu les aider mais vous avez
raison de relever que quand il ya du
désordre ça nourrit plutôt les extrêmes
que que les parties responsables et
c'est pour ça que c'est bien que le
gouvernement ne prenne des mesures en la
matière mais
on vit cette situation très particulière
où désormais la vie politique est coupée
en trois
et vous où les parties sont des extrêmes
vous oubliez absence et moi j'aimerais
oui mais oui au fond c'est normal que
des gens s'abstiennent si le choix
qu'ils ont c'est la majorité
présidentielle et deux extrémistes et
elle parce que quand on se retrouve dans
cette situation là voyez le moi je suis
très choqué au fond je préférerais qu'on
ait un débat entre cette majorité
centrale une gauche de gouvernement et
une droite de gouvernement oui mais vous
l'avez vous les avez vous les avez tué
d'une certaine façon parce que vous
aimez cartes et leurs députés et bien
mais pourquoi donc
parce que nous avons n'est pas capté
lors débuter là on a toujours 103 ou 104
débuté hier à l'assemblée nationale le
mans il ya toujours 27 ouvre c'est
l'assurance à
plusieurs reprises ce procès fait à
emmanuel macron et à la majorité un
constat qui voudrait que la droite
républicaine et la gauche républicaine
et disparus par notre fait c'est
pourquoi ils ont disparu c'est parce que
depuis cinq ans il pensait que emmanuel
macron était un accident de l'histoire
et ne nous majorité à faire en terre
serions d'une parenthèse bien oui mais
ça veut dire que pendant ce temps là ils
n'ont pas réfléchi et deux côtés ils se
sont fait totalement absorbé par jean
luc mélenchon et de l'autre on a une et
cette radicalité
vous arranger les tontons côté le pen
tente aux aînés côté vous savez que
c'est votre président donald c'est le
président de la république qui a theory
théorisé cette opposition entre les gens
qui sont dans la mondialisation et puis
les gens qui se sentent un peu laissés
pour compte les théories sont
représentés d'ailleurs parmi les ped il
est tiré une conséquence il adore il est
censé pouvoir moi je pense que gauche
républicaine et droite républicaine
frémit se remette à travailler d'accord
plutôt que se faire absorber par l'osec
sommes alors est-ce que
vous voyez avec crainte l'arrivée à la
présidence de la commission des finances
si j'avais ces danube est ce qui devient
votre premier parti d'opposition est
bien la règle veut c'est une coutume que
la commission des finances soit confié
la présidence au premier groupe
d'opposition est-ce que ça serait une
bonne chose mais je n'y verrais pas
d'inconvénient
à ce que j'ai toujours perçu
objections en fait s'est confiée à un
groupe d'opposition
moi je ne verrais aucun inconvénient
est ce que dans cette assemblée les
extrêmes qui habituellement s'exprime
dans la rue ou dans les médias soit plus
responsabiliser face aux responsabilités
parce que c'est facile de critiquer
c'est facile d'aller agité des grands
mots de de faire campagne sous
vociférations en prétendant que sa
personne est sacrée
ça n'a pas nui à jean luc mélenchon à la
présidentielle
on a fait un score excellent en
clair jean luc mélenchon il a perduré
présidentielle oui il a beau prétendre
qu emmanuel macron a pas gagné j'ai bien
l'impression que jean lui belge en a
perdu à la présidentielle là ils nous
demandent de les lire premier ministre
alors qu'il n'est pas candidat aux
élections législatives
ça ne soit pas un candidat d r non je
trouve ça complètement fou et le chou je
trouve ça et je trouve ça même un peu
dangereux dur au fond mais je vais pas
m'inquiéter de
capacité de la santé intellectuelle des
uns et les autres mais franchement
on demande aux gens de nous élire sans
être candidat alors que quand on a été
candidat on a perdu c'est un peu
dangereux pour la démocratie peut faire
croire aux gens qu'on pourrait être élu
sans être candidat et ça veut dire
qu'une fois qu'on est en place on va se
maintenir sans élection non plus est ce
que c'est on est en train de rentrer
dans une mécanique où tout le monde est
à l'envers donc on va se remettre à des
talents alors justement on va aller aux
élections
aller aux élections
est réélu parce qu'il est nerveux il est
maire du havre hui
les gens soient maires de grandes villes
ou alors ça mais je peux mais est ce que
est ce que vous allez garder la
présidence du groupe modem s'y est ce
que vous voulez la garde et je le
souhaite je souhaite rester acea
à votre mine inquiète sur le résultat de
ces listes est possible effectivement
depuis l'élection présidentielle il ya
eu le on a complètement changé le
contexte économique vous l'avez évoqué
avec brigitte tout à l'heure il ya eu
l'affairé abad
ya l'histoire du stade de france avec un
ministre de l'intérieur qui est un peu
dans le déni de réalité me semble-t-il
est ce que tout ça ça peut pas faire le
lit justement de vaud opposition est
tout à fait et le vrai risque dans cette
campagne électorale c'est qu'au fond sur
la base
d'une forme de désintérêt parce qu'au
lendemain d'une présidentielle on
s'intéresse peut-être un peu moins aux
élections législatives et puis
qu'ensuite de des éléments d'actualité
qui sont importants mais qui ne sont pas
en train de traiter les cinq années à
venir pour le pays effectivement il
puisse y avoir une forme d' accident
électoral moi je crains une forme d'
accident électoral qui conduisent bureau
font soit pour la majorité
présidentielle
qui conduisent le pays une forme
d'instabilité et donc moi je pense que
il faut redire ce qu'est l'enjeu le
président de la république il n'a pas
seulement été revu il a fixé une grande
ambition pour le pays laquelle est
l'ambition c'est d'avoir un new deal
économique et social un nouveau pacte
civil et social que je décrivais tout à
l'heure où parce que nous vivons dans
une société du plein emploi et de
l'inflation on doit adapter toutes les
relations économiques et sociales tous
les grands enjeux écologiques de demain
à une configuration qui est complètement
nouvelle et donc faut redonner de
l'optimisme aux français parce que s'ils
sont inquiets c'est parce qu'il sent
qu'il ya des changements fondamentaux
qui sont en train de travailler en
profondeur la société et qu'on n'y
répond pas c'est aux jeunes pourraient
revenir aux lignes de ses ventes si nous
ne parvenons pas à faire une chose c'est
tuer l'idée de résignation et de déclin
dans le pays il faut qu'on tue cette
idée de résignation et de déclin et que
nous nous soyons la majorité de la
stabilité est même question m rassurez
moi est ce que françois bayrou emmanuel
macron s'entendent toujours bien
jeune a cru voir monsieur bayrou un peu
déçu de la composition du gouvernement
oui mais pas très bien représentée
on a évité la sur-représentation
excessive mais les choses s'arrangeront
vos pensées s'arranger après les cet
hiver un remaniement moi je le souhaite
parce qu'il ya des il ya des personnes
qui sont talentueux je le dis d'autant
plus facilement que suis pas concerné
par le sujet puisque ayant fait un
infarctus il ya trois mois je vais pas
me jeter
faire la queue pour un ticket d'entrée
au gouvernement dia mais il ya des gens
talentueux au sein du mouvement
démocrate je le dis tout à l'heure de
nos députés qui bossent sur le terrain
et les nouveaux candidats démocrates
sous l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle sont des personnes qui
surtout
ressentent le pays ressentent la chair
du pays
que de nouveau rentrer au gouvernement
après les 7e merci et merci patrick
mignola d'avoir accepté notre invitation
des auditions publiques merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis pas d'audition
publique la semaine prochaine à cause de
la pentecôte mais vous retrouverez les
abete martichoux au lendemain du premier
tour des élections législatives très
bonne soirée sur lcp et public sénat
[Musique]